[Music]
well there it is
my beloved california absolutely
blanketed by smoke
somehow both apocalyptic and beautiful
at the same time
some would say it's not the best idea to
head right into this
least of all during a freaking pandemic
[Music]
but here i am with my mask collection
double pumps of hand sanitizer and my rv
bubble
that contains these two fine companions
like me they've been tested layered with
protocols
and chosen to interact with the world
our mission is to head out on route 395.
it's a road that runs down california's
eastern spine
and that offers up unfair amounts of
spectacular sights
the kinds of things that still produce
wonder amid a smoky haze
i mean come on
along the way we'll be visiting some of
the tech world's outliers
people that like to live and work on the
frontier
they're folks trying to feed the planet
fix it
or if need be just get off it
if thinking different is your thing then
here we go
show us the way rented rv with your
included dashboard ornament
show us the way
we're going 45 and a 70.
is that as fast as it goes
if you're gonna drive an rv through a
fiery hellscape during a pandemic
you want to be sure and do it right
alongside a massive
active fault system in this case may i
present
the walker lane which is often found
hugging
route 395.
well not as well known as say the san
andreas fault
it's the walker lane that gives 395 much
of its charm
we're talking hot springs extinct
volcanoes
and mountains and we're talking more
apocalypse
because it's now thought that the walker
lane may result in reno
ending up as a beach town
[Music]
who predicts such things well for one
this man geologist james faults
who forced me to climb this hill near
reno to learn about the fault
we are in the middle of the what's
called the walker lane
it's a big belt of faults in western
nevada also eastern california
the san andreas accommodates about 80
percent
of the motion between the pacific and
north american plates
and about 20 maybe as much as 25
of that motion is over here on on the
walker lane
folds is one of a growing number of
geologists who have become obsessed by
the walker lane fault
and what it could mean for residents of
california and nevada
in the distant future people focus so
much on the san andreas fault and what
this could mean and
in 10 million years to the geography of
the united states and california
but i mean there is the potential that
this fault could be
more even more dramatic if if some of
these theories are right we know the
walker lane
is growing northward along with the san
andreas so they're scheduled
to meet somewhere off the southern
oregon coast in about
maybe seven or eight million years and
what what does that look like
well when that happens what some of us
think
will occur is that the entire san
andreas then will sort of rip up through
the
uh western part of north america or the
we are the u.s
and it'll strand california off to the
west
i mean the pacific ocean ends up kind of
rushing through parts of nevada right
well or is that yeah this is
controversial
it'll be a slow process but we may have
beachfront property in reno someday
this fault also sort of brings along
some opportunities right
we have these crustal motions in the
region and in nevada there's a
stretching
of the crust stretching in the
horizontal dimension and that helps to
kind of
dilate or open up faults and that brings
hot water up closer to the surface
and then that can be tapped for
geothermal energy
[Music]
what's that jim did you say geothermal
energy
well then let's have a brief musical
interlude
as we gaze upon the nearby geothermal
plant
a vormont it's got everything awesome
fans
i mean really awesome fans wells that
tap into geothermal brine 10 000 feet
underground
sweet sweet pipes and transmission lines
turbines that you can't really see on
either side of this generator
enough juice for 22 000 homes
the walker lane fault in action back to
you
jim and then part of the reason
there was any controversy or we didn't
even know that much
about this fault was was 20 years ago it
was much harder to gather data
about this kind of thing the fault
wasn't as clear when
when you looked down and so what is this
device this is a gps station
so it's actually communicating with
satellites its position is
changing through time and those
satellites are tracking those changes
down to the scale of millimeters
how many are monitoring the fault
there's 400 of these sensors in this
region
in a network called magnets these
stations allow us to
sort of focus in on maybe what what the
most important part of the region
might be like how much activity
[Music]
are people around here seeing as a
result of the fault nevada is the third
third most seismically active state
after alaska and california
[Music]
after our chat james drove off and left
me with that unique brand of existential
dread
that comes from learning about the
perils of your surroundings
and what will befall humankind
to get rid of all that i had only one
option
a night spent at the splendid grand
sierra resort and casino rv
park where as it turns out you can still
get doordash
and eat your sorrows away
[Music]
all right let's see what it says to find
jp google maps will get you close to the
mailbox but not exactly there
expect a long gravel driveway
you got it yeah
from reno we headed south to carson city
well
like the outermost edge of carson city
where an old friend
is engineering a most unique existence
today we're a little bit outside of
carson city nevada
going to the house of jb stravel
he's a guy i've known for a long time he
was one of the first employees
at tesla and the longtime chief
technology officer i always thought of
him as the heart and soul of tesla
because he was this guy
who even before tesla was a real thing
he was obsessed
with solar-powered cars with
taking lithium-ion batteries and using
them to one day
reshape the automotive industry he was
kind of the dreamer
behind the technology in the whole
electric car revolution
a couple years ago he decided he was
going to go out
on his own and start a new company
around recycling all these lithium-ion
batteries that he helped create
we're going to learn a little bit more
about his life and then we're going to
go
see his new factory as well what's that
model three
yeah there's one tesla
two teslas three in the back
hey guys how are you i'm good
thanks for letting us do all this you've
like always
constantly got some project going on at
home or one or another
i mean i i love building things and you
know i kind of do this sort of stuff to
relax
this is the current project yeah this is
just sort of a side
fun project but it's a you know an
interesting experiment and being able to
do this you know cheaply and quickly and
find ways to deploy solar without
heavy equipment and it's just fun and
then even though you ran
tesla's energy division you still want
to you're building your own battery pack
right
it's i don't know i find more fun in the
process you know it's
you can pay someone to do something and
then it's just done and
but uh i think it's almost more the
journey and the you know the mental
exercise of thinking through it
jb started coming out here as tesla
began building its massive gigafactory
battery plant year by year
the charms of nevada grew on him and he
decided to stop living in hotels
and take over this fine compound
over the years elon musk has gotten all
of the tesla love in adoration
meanwhile jb quietly did his thing in
the background
always a tinkerer and engineer at heart
he spearheaded many of tesla's key
projects
before leaving the company in 2019
you come from a long line of of
tinkerers
uh tell me tell me a little bit about
your dad and your grandparents and
my great-grandfather actually uh you
know immigrated here
from germany and uh started an engine
company
in green bay wisconsin and they you know
he actually built machine
some of the very first internal
combustion engines for boats back then
for fishing boats
i mean it must be in the blood to some
degree because i know i mean you were
tinkering from like what when you're a
teenager or even before that
i just enjoy it you know it doesn't it
wasn't necessarily a
you know a means to an end it was just
something fun to do and
building things taking stuff apart it's
yeah it's what i do for fun
even in the early days i still remember
my dad taking me on
you know tours of power plants when i
was you know like this tall and didn't
know quite what i was looking at but i
thought it was all super cool and i
actually really loved chemistry in high
school that was
probably my favorite subject back then
and you know i had built a whole
chemistry lab in the basement
and was you know trying to learn about
all that on my own and understand you
know
batteries and electrochemistry stuff uh
even back then
you went to stanford and at stanford you
worked on
obviously this carried over because you
end up working on on the solar
racing team and i mean did you feel like
there was a revolution coming or this
was just something that was interesting
to you well it it felt early
you know it was you know things hadn't
taken off and it was very um
you know almost contrarian a little bit
thinking about solar
and solar car racing and this kind of
stuff i had an inkling that we were kind
of at the beginning of that transition
and you could clearly see the potential
overlapping into the end of that is is
when you know i i was spending much more
time you know really
digging into you know the earliest days
of electric vehicles
and starting to think more about
lithium-ion batteries and the solar car
racing stuff was was really the first
you know on-road application of anything
like that at some point there was a race
and and the team ends up crashing
at your house and this is right when the
lithium-ion batteries are turning up and
all these consumer electronic devices
you tell me a story wasn't this like the
moment where you guys were like maybe we
could lash all these things
together and i was actually living in
los angeles at the time in glendale
and it was only a few miles away from
where the race ended i called my buddies
and was like oh
come on over it's fun you know let's
we'll hang out and you can all crash in
the living room
we ended up you know staying up you know
most of the night you know reminiscing
about the race and
talking about the technology and how it
worked and
and you know hatched this crazy project
you know to um
to build you know a long-range electric
car ditch the solar panels
and just see if we could drive you know
almost a thousand miles on
on electricity alone it really i just
fell in love with it and it you know it
was such a fun project it just felt like
it had to be done
you know i saw no one else doing it and
wanted to throw myself into it
and in those days southern california
was kind of you know the mecca for
you know the early stages of electro
electric cars and batteries
so it was a good place to be
you end up with this guy martin eberhard
and mark tarpening they want to make an
an all-electric
sports car you've got elon down in la he
he's also kind of interested in this
idea and happens to have a lot of money
and and eventually these forces
combine and then and then you're right
there at the very
beginning as well there's some of the
best times you're thinking back on it
but it
it also you know we had no idea what we
were up against you know and trying to
imagine what it would become
um it was just a handful of people yeah
and you know no one had ever tried this
stuff before and
that was the beginning of you know how
we started to understand
large format batteries and how to
architect the safety of of that
and so that was the challenge right i
mean it was you guys were worried about
obviously
fires and then like how you cool these
things and there were explosions in the
the neighborhood well it was it was a
lot of trial and error i mean we
were fearless and we just you know
plunge into this and you know knowing
that somehow we'd figured this stuff out
but uh yeah i mean that we kind of built
it off the experience that came out of
even those earliest solar car
experiments but scaled it way up yeah
and had you know the support of a
growing engineering team and uh
you know more and more interest and
focus to really you know create what
became you know the roadster
[Music]
well this is uh this is a really old
roadster this was actually one of our
first engineering prototypes engineering
prototype 5 is what we called it
so a little bit before we started series
production you know years ago we
refurbished it and uh i sort of
collected this thing and i've taken care
of it since
i believe it's the oldest tesla that's
on the road still does it give you like
ptsd or or only memory
only only fond memories it's it's a
great thing to you know get in there and
remember
what evs were you know were like not
that long ago and it's incredible how
fast the development has happened
these days jb is all about batteries and
what we should do with them
he left tesla to start redwood materials
at its heart it's a battery recycling
company
but looked at another way it's sort of
like a lithium or nickel mine
just in reverse sort of a startling
amount of phones this is
a big bit of phones man well yes one of
many
redwood has a lot of batteries i believe
the technical term
is a ton consumers send them in
so do companies this is basically some
of the incoming material that we get you
know from consumers so
you know it's a whole variety of stuff
just 18 650s
scooter battery pack even you know power
tool battery packs it's like a power
pack thing
you know but this has a battery in it so
you know it's difficult to dispose of
and we can recycle this for the
materials
we're inventing the ways you know that
you can basically recycle this without
having a human do it because
it's too small how much lithium that's
been used in here would you guys be able
to recover
like what's the reuse percentage almost
all of it you know lithium maybe
more than 80 percent nickel 95
98 same with cobalt and copper
so you know it's a pretty complete
process
[Music]
redwood gets devices takes out the
batteries and then begins breaking them
down into their elemental parts
this is largely done through heat
serious heat
which is why these space men are needed
they're using an oven to create what is
basically
metal magma which then goes into a tub
and is stirred with a rake
because why not redwood then goes
through chemical
and other processes to end up here
mounds of stuff that was once pulled
from the ground
and can now be reused
we got some more metal over here yeah
this is just a small batch of lithium
carbonate that we just made this morning
and
this is sort of a chance to see what the
the final product is and what lithium
actually looks like you know once you
extract it from the batteries and
separate it out
so you know this stuff is is quite pure
lithium carbonate so this is actually
the the input precursor
of how lithium gets you know used and
built back into batteries
it is pretty neat to see it separated
like this and uh
you know know that this came from
batteries you know that were you know
otherwise you know garbage and otherwise
wouldn't have been recovered
i mean it's like the lithium say it's
been in my phone
and you guys refine it how many times
can that
happen can this just keep going on and
on and on there's no
there's no real limit to it there's no
degradation that happens to those atoms
of lithium or cobalt or nickel
and it's one of the coolest things about
this is that those metals are basically
infinitely recyclable
except for the small amounts that get
lost in the recycling process itself you
can basically keep doing that again and
again and again
so you can start to imagine a future
where you're thinking huh like if we can
do this
a thousand times you know the need for
mining new materials
starts to dwindle that's cool
after a hard day of alchemy jb will head
home and tend to his nerd garden
that might mean expanding the solar farm
or fiddling with his homemade
mountaintop internet repeaters
or obviously letting that still running
sexy yellow roadster loose
remember kids study hard work hard
find a super rich friend with a mars
fetish who believes in electric cars
just as much as you do
and this can all be yours too
on the next hello world we meet a guide
who knows california's best kept secrets
if i see a dirt road i just want to go
down and find some robots
working the central valley's farms you
know what i either got to get out of
this business
or i'm going to innovate
ashley we just watched part one of a
three-part series of you taking hello
world
on the road highway 395 on the eastern
side of california
um tell us a little bit about what we're
expecting to see
over the course of the three episodes
and what we just saw in this one
first of all part of it's just pretty
scenery because 395 is this amazing
road that obviously takes you from
desert and death valley up to giant
mountain peaks and
obviously lots of people in california
know it but maybe outside of california
this is not one of the
things that jumps up but it's some of
the most beautiful spots
and then the scientists and inventors
and companies they kind of match up with
the terrain
it's it's like all these people that
like to be
basically sort of off the grid and doing
things out you know where it's dusty and
sandy and gritty
and getting dirty did you know about the
walker lane
fault before we did that i know i had
never and okay and this is embarrassing
because i grew up in california i had
never heard of walker landfall i'm
i i grew up in the bay area so it's like
the um hayward fault is like a big one
that i feel like we talked about a lot
and because it ran
near my childhood house in fremont um
and i mean i love the scenery of the
eastern sierra so i was
moved by just seeing like how that was
created by
you know the deep geology under under
the earth is pretty cool the director
david nicholson who you can see
in the episode you know he's the one
who's telling me about this fault i'm
like i haven't even heard of this man i
mean
how big of a deal can this be and then i
start reading about it i was like oh god
this could be
like in some ways more dramatic than san
andreas
and then and then there's this whole we
get into it a little bit in the episode
but if anyone wants to go
read online our geologist
james he's he's kind of like part of a
conscious is a semi-controversial
camp you know who's who's like the
they're like the walker lane fault
people as opposed to the
san andreas fault and and so i think you
know especially the last 20 years it
seems like there's been a lot of
debate about how big default actually is
and how much it's
moving and so all this this technology
just in the last couple of years has
helped them
bolster their case that the walker lane
fault is a big deal but yeah i didn't
know there was like fault politics among
geologists until
until we we really got into this yeah
what about so i just thought your
interview with jb was really good
um it sounds like probably he's been
someone you've talked to for a long time
like when did you first meet him
well yeah so i mean jb is you know he's
one of these guys that
he's been there since the beginning of
tesla and so so he was kind of always
in there in the news stories and then i
got to know him better
when i started writing a book about sort
of tesla's history and elon and spacex
and all that stuff and i just thought
from the first time i met him it just
struck me that this guy was
really yeah he was sort of the passion
part of
of the lithium-ion battery is it going
electric and all the climate change kind
of like all the reasons you would want
to make an electric car company actually
meant
something really deep to this guy
because he'd been doing it since he was
in university
and then obviously if you work for elon
musk at any of his companies it's like
elon that's
getting all the attention and and i sort
of think that's why
it worked for jb to stay at tesla so
long is that you know he never really
sought
attention or wanted any of the limelight
so that usually works pretty well
if you're willing to stay in the shadows
but uh
you know now that so he started his own
company i just felt like um
well he's an interesting guy he's humble
he's smart and then
he's sort of a guy who deserved some
attention and to have some of his story
told i don't think a lot of people have
heard this stuff before and had
do i saw that his company only announced
what they were doing
like a couple months ago so like did you
know he was working on something like
that and then
were sort of waiting for when they were
ready to talk about it or how did that
come together
yeah it was public when he left tesla
and even when he left tesla he's like
i'm gonna go do something
vaguely to do with battery recycling but
he wasn't real specific and then just
when we were
producing this episode he had reached
out to me and he's like we're gonna
finally tell everyone exactly what we're
doing and i was like oh great this is a
perfect time it will come be like the
first film crew
to film it all and then it ended up
being like
i think like further along than i
expected i mean
especially when you see the big factory
in that that footage it was
pretty massive in person and he's always
pretty humble so
you know he sells himself okay but maybe
not like some other people it was
it seemed like they're doing all right
they might actually
pull this off when it seems like the
main problem is getting the cost
of like it's presumably pretty expensive
to recycle the lithium
and you would just want it to make sense
for a company to choose to do that
rather than mining something new
he talks about the episode a bit but
like seeing it firsthand you could just
tell that like the variety
of all these batteries is such a pain
and i kept
asking it's just struck me it's still
like a very manual
process i couldn't see how you would
have a robot that could could adjust to
all these different battery sizes and
the way you'd strip them out and he
i felt like he never fully answered that
question really clearly and i tried to
hit him with it like three or four times
and yet i didn't see like a ton of
people in the factory and so i was
trying to figure
that piece out i mean he he kept talking
about how they
obviously need to automate that part of
the process but
it seemed that seemed like the trickiest
thing to me that they'll have to figure
out
wait how long were you on the road for
the for the whole trip
the whole trip was roughly like 10 days
um
and yeah full rv the whole time which
was cool
i mean i always enjoy going overseas but
it's great when you can go
explore your backyard and and also
full confession which is a shameful
confession and i i don't like explore
california as much as i should you know
we have all this
stuff right here and and i'd been on
like i'd been to death valley and like
bits and pieces of 395 yosemite and
things like that but
i never really explored it and so yeah
it was a great excuse to go
do that get out of the office get out of
the house
[Music]
you